hi guys this is Luca from Lucca Don
Pardo's comm and today we're going to
deal with the second section of the Q&A
that we're going to see today thank you
very much for all the questions that you
asked me and keep asking the questions
in the comment section below please
today we're going to look at I have I
hold a piece of paper here for questions
in four different languages and we're
going to start with English happier on a
horse asks me does your communication
style and personality change from
language to language or between skill
levels has the overall way to
communicate changed as a result of
learning multiple languages would you
would love to hear your you share
specifics and thanks for your wonderful
videos thank you very much happy Iran or
sauna know your real name
but the YouTube name and I'll get to you
in a second let me put this down so
imagine a prism and imagine this prism
to be differentiated from prison so a
prism that his hit by light normally
that's the way we can dissect light and
we can see the multiple components of
light human beings are like that prism
and languages are those different colors
of light that we can see I don't think
that speaking languages changes my
personality per se because I always have
my own personality but it shows
different facets of my personality so I
think that the more languages you speak
the more facets of your personality you
can actually show to the rest of the
world and you can discover yourself and
of course I do change my Co gestures my
hand gestures my facial features the
movement of my body the way I'm speaking
now the very same gestures I'm using now
are not the gestures I would use if I
were speaking Italian but that's just an
external code of communicating I'm just
using a different
so remember my personality does not
change but what changes is the colorful
possibilities that I have to show my
soul to the rest of the world now on to
the second question asked by Raul
Carvajal in French so I will provide in
French cuckoo Luca desert le premier
motivation pour upon : s key Adele on
cachaça Messiah Yeshua ret echoes
dysentery al-aqsa do Christian different
of it le premier motivation città di le
premier Nicosia please
a local rebel Patrol schewe Longley le
francais
Yahweh just said do not develop Ronaldo
ungawa DCD the Jews como se upon a
pleasure commander controller Alma La
Paz school java vm crib allah television
DVD CD do Kumasi Pasco namilama para
Knesset rebel Alma is Ravi Antonio
palais de l'alma come along present
result grey literature philosophy to say
inoculate surely como second say a
prayer less panel recommends approval is
illumine co co ltd say Paul Alma si
bemol
t-mobile GT team impatient APIs admitted
coach mmm como se upon dole espanol
Drammen festro
appear on country in Nana on Sardinia
una alone des francais aprende roland a
yeah otro Rizzo - Rizzo kolonko
depressed sad upon della Strada pondered
rested upon du de las casas the
circumstance Exeter Exeter
Osaki consolidation Castro Giacomo say
upon voluma Illya Rockwell season on
Caicos Kansa a Julia bundling with julie
a noorie Pascal ba na CL excellent
Cassie wasn't Indonesian - I this was a
normal shock master upon Illuma
bascarsija metidq julia pondhawk echo
shows in long relative more facility not
along
difficile tailor shop owner Stephanie
her husband Tony later lucuma upon money
Pascoe hello Lou Malnati's magazine may
may soon see reports cool no problem
principles I take Jenna Pat who we do
not even a puppet at who will prove a
tentative there's no away key ballet
dogs inevitably in Hula's show havoc the
person epic on sale is along a summer
papazoni response cassette pasa la razón
por la que Ella Giovanni Laguna pass
quiz every no news on utility longer
control commence a lipoma also key
concern Lulu Japanese chef a video a
pupusa legit je parle de fête capri avec
limited keen ownership at cumbia a don't
Sam hongcheon no memo is a MIDI collages
of to pass good loser operates as long
as he completed the third question is
from Chile that's his name from Chile
and he has - question in Spanish
Luca tengo una grande una to mention
hace el principio los primeros
says mrs. lo que haces s traducere
textos elimyaye room idioma pero me do
da days como puedes traducere sin tener
conocimiento stay gramatica me de
vocabulario porque el asunto no es
traducere un para 40 Rondo lo a Google o
traducere un para focus condo palabra
poor palabra como lo haces sin tener
essa spaces
del idioma suna pregunta muy necesaria
para mí y para muchos kisses muchas
gracias Luca desde yeah
saludos desde cielo para para contest
are a two pregunta yo diría que no
puedes empezar days Tesoro utilize ando
textos KN cuentas and internet tienes
utilize aroun text ok say a possible
meant a compressible ax y que c'est
possible meant a bilingual canoe do y es
a la razón por la cual yo siempre
applica esta traducción be directional
al assimil a esta serie de materiales
para los que quieran aprender idiomas
porque es un text OB lingua
Amidala posibilidad de atilla's our
millennium aterna ii Maleng guaa meta
para traducere entonces yo no necesito
traducere no necesito buscar vocabulario
y romantica por que todo esta muy bien
explica doughy sí quiero puedo comprar
la estructura de los dos idiomas yad
MSCI puntos y cosas que yo no entiendo
con simplemente compare and o los
idiomas puedo hacer UN beast a so a las
explications chromatic a lays que estan
pour a entonces lo que te a consejos
para implement arla truck CMB
directional necesitas tener material
compressible ax e material que te gusta
esto es lo más importante y con internet
a no necesitas necessary meant a tomar
un corso como se mil podría stoma our
podcast otros materials otro recursos
que possession contra internet pero lo
más importante es que estos recursos
sayin otra vez come Prince ablaze audio
si puede tener el texto una transcript
theone adele audio ipod Yasuda Lazar for
example o tambien Google Translate k and
muchos estos casos de permit a today at
Roxy own be directional bastante Buena
como para aplicar latter accion
Direction le and now on to the fourth
and final question at that Marvel a nyan
ask me hello Luca shut permission DECT
that's the South Tower they have this
dishes off DNA on so acting dumb
underdog
Amira Clyde in caul fat on top laying
out or a child in con algún ooh Clinton
is Vistage and if the gonna a nail made
feel the woo cost on vanished suka hot
this room is best
oops you old baby isn't move you older
than half are hung and damn it in classy
on danke want Bieber cruiser dunk a
foodie Frogger
Marvin Linea on SS fish em laugh at that
side I wish me milky gave him only the
Frog at Subhan Thornton then feel the
Lord the Frog mr. GaN society's
development on the spa
Edmond Irish father of a letter sight I
wish all fashion under Oscar phone
versus their service dishes on the sales
document on Indies in st. riding there
the Vistage undestand who lesson good
Slaven owned a plane going to famine on
disc Lauer as I team is angling harbour
free after stain my bets mocking ha an
offense vermin my nanny and marking on
the DND I'm glutton on an status mocking
than Lisa Mason Dan Hibiki on Fang our
ops bamboo shook Suisun my main guitar
music activist lesson on Dan who Shravan
dan hat sesh Alice Finland on top
murbach me energy Moroccans ecozone
Schriever HD of Shabak - lon
sparks pozzolan impact la from from
Allahabad to Auburn and flower does is
cans wastage shop for cotton
Alvin Gentry Santa's population thus
damn it garbage quests V does Internet
UN's Finland on this global young on was
a Shannon engrosses consent cartoons
problem and this flower does visa
Spartan a fitzy enter on a chanela to
learn is a sign of Hager their
constituency own so there you have it
I've entered these four questions in
four different languages if you want to
know more please ask in the comment
section below thank you for all the very
interesting questions that you've been
asking so far and I'm eager to reply to
more in more languages
thank you very much for listening to me
and see you very soon here on YouTube
bye
you
you